so getting in our final video on the
story of deadpool vs status there's
actually not a lot of room for
interpretation regarding the characters
themselves instead the ending of this
story is largely just action with a
bunch of funny moments now getting into
this and last video we had discussed
that is status and deadpool were in the
realm of Mephisto deadpool had died and
experienced another vision for mistress
death leading way to believe that she
was being held captive by eternity the
living manifestation of the universe now
the conversation between eternity and
mistress death is very important here
and that because mistress death is the
physical representation of death itself
she is truly immortal and will stand at
the end of all things including the
death of the universe and eternity
himself and so to keep her from bringing
about the end of all things as is the
natural course of life eternity
kidnapped mistress death in order to
keep anything from dying including
himself now in the midst of eternity z'
rant that you were greeted with the
arrival of the in-betweener if you
recall our discussion on the Infinity
Gauntlet and the cosmic entities we
talked about how two of these beings are
called master order and Lord chaos as
the representation of order and chaos
the two we created the in-betweener to
serve in order to ensure that chaos and
order were maintained in the universe as
such the in-betweener works best as a
non-biased intermediary and looks to
have eternity free mistress death as her
purpose maintains order and without her
creates chaos however as in-betweener
reasons with eternity
Deadpool Athena's arrived following
their experience with Mephisto one thing
that Seeley does here though which is
pretty interesting is that he closes out
one of the lingering plot threads by
telling us that with Mephisto is realm
under siege by the other hell lords
Thanos and Deadpool had helped to call
the threat and in turn were given
passage to where death was being held
what's also funny is that Deadpool is
completely overwhelmed by the fact that
he's basically standing in a massive
void of emptiness with the universe
represented as a giant guy who is
basically holding mistress death hostage
while in the presence of the
metaphysical representation of order and
chaos all in the midst of everyone's
inability to die and so using the
conversation between the in-betweener
and eternity as a distraction the
intention of Thanos is to rescue
mistress death and escape without anyone
noticing
however when Thanos arrives at her side
death pulls one of the biggest dick
moves of all time when she ignores
status
calls out to deadpool rushing to the
side of his main squeeze deadpool knocks
Thanos out of the way something that's
also funny here is a death it makes it
that's what she said joke when Wade
tells her to give him some of the bone
but while all this is happening but
while all this is happening Thanos is
getting more and more pissed off
reaching his breaking point and lashing
out Thanos is angry for a couple reasons
here the first is because you spend his
entire life struggling to gain the
affections of mistress death only to be
denied again the second is because he is
under word all the foolishness of Wade
to get to this point and the third
instead of all the people he could be
turned down for he was turned down for
canadian however because of his actions
and freaking out he's drawn the
attention of eternity and in-betweener
both of whom are far more powerful than
either Thanos or Deadpool and so
banishing the in-betweener and intending
to kill thanos the initial reaction of
Black Talon is that they're all doomed
and that there's no way they can stand
against the power of this magnitude but
as mr. stead states she's the embodiment
of death and the only people who can die
are those who she rolls to die something
that I would also like you to notice
here is that Sealy reconciles a concept
of death and saying that while there are
many manifestations of her character
with different races or individuals in
the realm of mysticism seeing her
different ways they all see the same
person
and so because eternity represents life
in the form of all living things in the
universe and death or resents the end of
all living things the two are basically
opposites imbuing Thanos and Deadpool
with their power the two have
effectively become the physical avatars
of death now using their vast power both
Thanos and Deadpool find themselves
working together to defeat eternity is
something I'd also like you to notice is
that much like Thanos during the
Infinity Gauntlet his absolute power has
led him to become arrogant and drunk
with the power that he has at the same
time he also despises his own existence
from the perspective of Thanos he does
not have the ability to control what
mistress death does and because she
appeared to him when he was younger and
unable to realize what she was doing she
had basically lured him into a trap
where he was constantly pursuing the
love of her and never receiving it what
this tells us is that in truth
Thanos doesn't view his life as being
his own fault and has basically removed
himself from the responsibility of his
own actions
and that he could have walked away from
mistress death at any point in time
instead he chose to stay attached to her
and blame the universe for his refusal
to leave and so after beating eternity
within an inch of his life and possibly
ending all existence Deadpool steps in
and stating that he and Thanos could get
together for a three-way with mistress
death and the Thanos can spank Ted pool
if he wants to
however after lashing out that was a tax
Deadpool but what happens next is
extremely important and it's actually
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head where Deadpool is
knocked out of the fray by Thanos
mistress death in turn strip some of his
power over death meaning the Deadpool
can now die if Thanos chooses to kill
him now on its face this seems to be an
instance where death has cast aside her
favor of Wade and preference of Thanos
furthermore without his power
Deadpool continues his efforts to defeat
Thanos and even goes as far as the
reference the importance of the Golden
Girls which is awesome
because the Golden Girls is one of the
best shows to ever have existed because
it gave us Betty White attacking
Deadpool in turn by throwing him through
eternity and back into the universe the
plan of mistress death comes into full
fruition when Deadpool is cast back into
the universe but doesn't die he's met
with the arrival of the uni power as a
refresher for this concept the unit
power is the sum total of all power in
the universe and exists to ensure the
protection of eternity as such the unit
power is sentient but requires a host or
to achieve its goal of protecting all
life however the unit our only bonds
itself with individuals who are worthy
and responsible but because the
situation is so dire with all existence
on the edge of destruction should Thanos
kill eternity the unit power makes the
case that in this instance beggars can't
be choosers transitioning back to Thanos
as he prepares to deal the final blow to
eternity which again would see the end
of all that is and its rebirth
understand owes Deadpool makes his
appearance as Captain universe imbued
with the power of everything in
existence as a result he has cosmic
awareness and is able to see and feel
all things including the fact that
Thanos hasn't changes underwear in four
days something also like here is that
Deadpool provides himself with several
new names including captain unit pool
which is an amazing name and in my
opinion you guys should tweet to Marvel
telling them that you want a captain
uniforms story and so facing off against
one another with your incredible power
the story finally lives up to its title
with Deadpool and Thanos fighting one
another
as a literal battle between life and
death and truth the fate of all that
exists depends on this fight meaning
that if Deadpool loses all things will
end and be reborn
but if Deadpool succeeds the universe
will continue on something that's also
interesting here is that Deadpool uses
Thanos as previous words against him
what I mean here is that in the last
issue
Thanos had complemented Wade on the fact
that through his battles with Ajax he
had endured hell in terms of his torture
and proved to be strong willed and that
he returned and killed Ajax in turn
however during his fight Fano states
that the only true honesty lies in death
and the beliefs that come with it
including desolation and suffering
combating Thanos is belief Deadpool
temporarily casts aside his comedic
nature and provides an important wisdom
what he says is that in addition to that
owes having previously expressed a
respect for Wade's ability to endure the
worse of situations and cut out stronger
the Thanos himself does not represent
death the same way that he thinks he
does the case that Wade makes here is
that when Thanos was born his mother
viewed him as being a bad omen as such
she decided to kill him and without
survived only to endure taunts and a
life of Hell by other members of his
race in the end he endured it all to
become what he is today this coupled
with the fact that Thanos has routinely
attempted to gain absolute power which
by extension keeps him alive in the end
he truly serves life more so than he
serves death and so picking up on this
mistress death strips Thanos of her
power reverting him back to his normal
form and in doing so ends the conflict
between himself and Deadpool at the same
time because the crisis is over an
eternity huge destruction has been
averted the unit power leaves Deadpool
sending him back to his normal form as
well all while mistress death leaves
back to her realm and so as the story
begins to wind down and come to its end
weight is greeted by eternity who makes
the case that Thanos has most likely
been stowed away by mistress death until
she calls on him during the events of
secret Wars and while the belief of
eternity is that Deadpool does not
require any compensation for his actions
in the end weight is still a mercenary
and so asking for 60% of the money
earned from his captain universe variant
action figures which don't exist but
definitely should because I would buy
one
Deadpool requests that he be sent back
to earth and as he points to its
location learns the Eternity is ticklish
and begins chasing him around
from here we learn that with mistress
death returning to her position the
universe is being restored to its
normalcy with all organisms and life
itself returning to the cycle of life
and death during this time deadpool also
pays a visit to dr. doom where he
reveals all of the information of the
event as is transpired because the
captain Unipol action figure did not
sell well the goal of Deadpool is to
have dr. doom remove his armor and a lab
way to kill him so that he can cash in
on the reward money refusing to offer
and blasting refusing the offer and
blasting Deadpool out of Latveria the
story comes to a close with Black Talon
revealing that he's freeing all the
zombies being held captive on his Island
the reason being that because to him he
spent his entire life worshipping death
and mysticism but after witnessing the
most recent conflict he's chosen to cast
this life aside in favor of pursuing
different goals in his life with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and I'm all about you
guys but I really enjoyed the Deadpool
vs. Thanos stories let me know down in
the comments section whether or not you
guys enjoyed it too and I will catch you
guys later peace